spüren sie das eigentlich auch noch
wenige stunden bis zur wahl und es liegt
was in der luft eine jamaika-koalition
freunde der das toll oder jamaika ja
natürlich
das muss kommen das muss kommen noch
eine groko und wir kriegen die
österreichische verhältnisse der ganze
stillstand muss weg sicher die frau
merkel wer dann immer noch kanzlerin da
machst du eh nix dran wie viele jahre
regierte jetzt schon am stück weil er
mal 2005 67 2018 2019 hält 13 14 punkte
ja
das war anton hofreiter mit den
lottozahlen vom freitag
die ewige merkel
es ist so zwölf jahre und kein ende in
sicht dann aber wenigstens jamaika damit
sich mal irgendetwas bewegt hier zum
verkannte rinn ist es doch völlig wohnte
welchem koalitionspartner sie als
nächstes zu grunde richten oder er ist
also gerade kleine parteien sollten froh
sein dass die frau überhaupt noch ihren
namen kennt
da bin ich normalerweise sehr tolerant
wenn es um die grünen gilt oder die spd
geht oder die die fdp geht
richtig
ja
die fdp
immer und die fdp die hatte sich schon
völlig verdrängt ne hab ich dir auch mal
kaputt gemacht trotzdem wollen die
liberalen wohl wieder mit merkel
regieren
der medizinische fachbegriff lautet
glaube ich masochismus kurz nachgehakt
wofür steht jetzt die neue fdp klientel
politik populismus ausbeutung und
umweltzerstörung lassen leuten mit wenig
geld allein die fdp hat darum schlägerei
auch politik für die vergangenheit
richtig dagegen partei nur eigen-pr
verfügungs rhetorik sicher einfach aber
du ja okay danke habe ich mir alles
vorher gedacht ja wenig
wenn ich aber gut dass sie jetzt so
selbst kräftig mit vielen dank
aber jetzt mal die entscheidende frage
leute wie passenden grüne liberale und
union inhaltlich zusammen in so einer
merkwürdigen neuen koalition
kurz gesagt gar nicht die grünen wollen
eine bürgerversicherung und den
kohleausstieg und die fdp nicht es muss
trotzdem jamaika und privat sind lindner
und ärzte mir doch bfs das geht ja fast
schon in den romantischen bereich nur
die eisblöcke challenge habe ich ihn zu
füttern er hat mich nämlich nominiert
das wissen viele gar nicht er hat mir
das eingehandelt hier systems du weißt
du vielleicht gar nicht auch ich weiß
das
[Applaus]